Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en 24 no a ustedes
Muchas gracias por la invitación Estoy
muy contenta de poder estar con ustedes
tendial mujeres olvidadas es tu primer
poemario y su portada es muy linda la
verdad muy poética pero después de la
lectura de tu libro La vemos de otra
manera siento vemos las marcas que deja
la violencia en los cuerpos de las
mujeres te quería preguntar quién la
dibujó y cuál era la idea detrás de esta
portada Sí pues en realidad ten vi
lalancetic parte de Los feminismos
comunitarios y descoloniales para
denunciar las violencias físicas
sexuales y feminicidas que están
ocurriendo en contextos hostiles pero
que me parece que no solo un tema que
estamos viviendo las mujeres hostiles no
es un tema que estamos viviendo en
general las mujeres en México y en todo
el mundo no entonces pues un poquito la
Ilustración lo hizo una chica de la
Ciudad de México
y ella leyó el poemario y en base a
lo que le inspiró sabes pues retrató eso
no y me parece una imagen muy poderosa
porque es a la mujer con el rostro sí
fuerte no Guerrero a pesar de todas
estas violencias que una vive no O sea
ver toda esta violencia pero recordar
también la fuerza que tenemos como
mujeres para salir de estos procesos de
violencia y escribiste este poemario y
luego hiciste tú misma la traducción al
español nunca sentiste una frustración
durante Durante este ejercicio dado el
hecho de que una traducción nunca va a
poder Reproducir exactamente el ritmo y
el color de todas esas palabras que tú
elegiste Pues yo creo que el proceso de
traducción es muy difícil no es muy
complejo incluso hacerlo del español al
subsidio del tzotzilla al Castellano
viene en realidad es como un proceso
complejo la traducción sin embargo yo
creo que siendo bilingües pues no nos
movemos en estos dos mundos sabes de
repente estás pensando en socil pero de
repente ahora piensas en castellano y es
como que sabe siendo personas bilingües
ya nos da la posibilidad de estar en
estos dos dos este espacios si es
complejo lleva su tiempo es un proceso
largo no cansado no te lleva meses sino
muchísimos muchísimos tiempo para lograr
Traducir pero me parece que
que alcanza no a traducir lo que estamos
queriendo decir y este libro está
dividido en tres secciones la primera
alma heridas después cuerpos y
sentimientos despojados y voces
silenciadas esta dinámica de tres
tiempos tres partes ya la tenías Clara
cuando quisiste escribir el libro sí
totalmente No desde un inicio ya tenía
como claro estos tres apartados no
hablar primero desde la violencia mínima
que vivimos hasta el último de la
violencia más alto como son homicidios
no entonces comienzo como desde la
violencia física desde la discriminación
el racismo que vivimos como mujeres
tóxiles pero luego como esta violencia
va aumentando no Y cómo después ya nos
enfrentamos a violencia sexual es por
parte del papá del tío del hermano no
Entonces como va escalando esta
violencia no Y cómo están agrediendo a
nuestros cuerpos como mujeres no y luego
pues también traer a la memoria las
compañeras que han sido Víctimas de
feminicidio no que es el último apartado
que es muy desgarrador pero me parece
que muy importante nombrarlo y
denunciarlo porque las compañeras sí se
vivieron feminicidio pero nuestros
contextos no se habla del feminicidio no
se escucha hablar del feminicidio en las
ciudades en las urbes no pero no en
nuestros contextos como que si no
ocurriera sin embargo Sí están
ocurriendo también estas violencias y
Pues ten vilar ante ti que es una manera
de denunciarlos de nombrarlos y hacer
justicia por por ellas y cada sección de
tu libro está introducida por las
palabras de una escritora primero las
argentinas alfonsinas torni y Alejandra
pizarnik y luego la mexicana Araceli
platanie Quiénes son estas mujeres para
ti pues han sido bastante importante
dentro de mi trayectoria no O sea cuando
empecé a escribir estos poemas que eran
como de la violencia Y del dolor pues
tuve que buscar referentes no también
hacer una lectura no de de mujeres que
estuvieran escribiendo temas pues muy
dolorosos no y las tres autoras que
planteo aquí pues son compañeras que que
escriben desde el dolor desde la rabia
desde la tristeza desde la agonía no y
Araceli patriani la última es una
compañera que escribe también en lenguas
originarias y que ella también habla
sobre esta cuestión de de las
desapariciones no en su contexto en su
pueblo Y entonces retomo también es este
apartado de uno de sus poemas que se
titula yo no quiero sino mal recuerdo y
que me parece muy poderoso no que
refleja también el último apartado que
son los feminicidios no y su si te
refieres de manera constante a las
abuelas entonces tus poemas que sí Cuál
es su conexión que sientes con tus
abuelas y como esa conexión alimenta Tu
arte pues las abuelas creo que son
sumamente importantes no porque
son sabias y ellas nos han mostrado la
fuerza no O sea ella se vivieron un
montón de violencia hacia aún así
resistieron y estuvieron ahí no Entonces
yo creo que recordarlas para mí siempre
es muy poderoso no recordar a mis
abuelas siempre va a ser necesario para
tomar esa fuerza esa rabia ese coraje
recordar y decir vamos a hacer justicia
porque ustedes no pudieron nombrar estas
situaciones que vivieron pero que es
necesario hacerlo y
a mí me trae mucha mucha energía sabes
mucha fuerza y decir si podemos lo vamos
a nombrar pues ya que es difícil y a lo
mejor trae repercusiones no pero
necesario y hay una exposición en esta
edición de la filbo en el pabellón de
México de la fotografía
santis ella y la fotógrafa misa Morales
que es colombiana participaron a un
conversatorio y explicaron que
ellas quieren desde el arte cuestionar
su propio territorio guardar la memoria
ancestral y entender su experiencia de
mujer indígena hoy en día eso sí son las
artistas mujeres indígenas las que están
moviendo las cosas Pues yo creo que
ahora nos estamos posicionando No que
estamos como alzando la voz y lo estamos
haciendo a través del arte no y que eso
es bastante importante no que el arte
nos ha permitido poder pues nombrar las
cosas que están ocurriendo en nuestros
contextos no es una fotógrafa a la que
yo admiro muchísimo no que es de del
pueblo y que me parece que estamos Este
ella Desde la fotografía Yo desde la
poesía otras compañeras desde el teatro
desde la pintura no desde las artes
visuales
hablando de los temas que nos mueven y
los temas que nos aquejan no y que me
parece que es necesario
tomar el arte como una manera de nombrar
de decir lo que estamos viviendo en
nuestros contextos porque anteriormente
nuestras abuelas o incluso ahora en la
actualidad en las comunidades todavía no
tenemos la oportunidad de nombrar y de
hablar y de decir no en las asambleas
comunitarias por ejemplo pues no podemos
no hablar ni toma no tenemos
derecho a tomar la palabra en nuestros
contextos no Entonces yo creo que el
arte ha sido como una manera de de poder
decirlo y nos ha ayudado un montón
y durante la presentación de tu libro
juntaste que no solo el fósil y el
español te sirven para producir un arte
único y resistir ante la hegemonía
lingüística son idiomas que te ayudaron
a acompañar niñas Víctimas de violencia
sexuales y hacer traducción para ellas
nos puedes hablar de esta situación en
México de esta desigualdad ante las
lenguas Sí pues a mí me ha tocado
acompañar niñas Víctimas de violencia
sexual no y que son niñas mayas hostiles
y que cuando se enfrentan a estos
sistemas de Justicia la fiscalía tienen
que pasar con el psicólogo con el médico
perito pues estas instituciones no
tienen la capacidad para atender a las
niñas no Entonces se comunican en
castellano una lengua que las niñas Pues
no ha no hablan que es más bien Su
lengua es el sutil y que yo he hecho
este trabajo de traducción de
acompañamiento es una traducción
simultánea no como ha sido muy difícil y
muy desgarrador escuchar historias
porque tenemos que escuchar en sotil y
luego tener que traducir al MP que está
levantando como la carpeta de
investigación entonces
pues lo hace muy doloroso y yo creo que
ese esa acumular tanto dolor y tantas
historias me dio como la el coraje de
escribirlo y decir esto estamos viviendo
esto pasó hace muchísimos años con
nuestras abuelas pero también está
pasando ahorita en la actualidad o sea
un 2023 en Chiapas las niñas sociles
están viviendo violencia sexual por
parte del hermano del tío del papá y es
lo que está ocurriendo y hay que
denunciarlo hay que nombrarlo para que
las niñas ya no callen sabes y tu poema
si un día no vuelvo a casa
me hizo pensar a la canción de otra
artista mexicana Silvana Estrada su
canción Si me matan ella escribió en
México son asesinadas más de 10 mujeres
al día pretende ser bálsamo que llegue a
tus hermanas amigas madre o tu hija hay
que entender que no estamos solas sobre
todas las cosas hay esperanza Susi tú
crees en el arte como poder sanador
Incluso en las situaciones más dolorosas
injustas Sí a mí me parece que es una
manera de liberarse y de sanar con una
misma porque a mí me pasó En lo
particular no sanar Mi historia a través
de ten vilalancetic porque pude
nombrarlo cuando no puedo hacerlo en
otros espacios a mí la poesía me da la
oportunidad y yo creo que sí que la
poesía nos va a dar la oportunidad de
sanar no y que el primer paso yo creo es
escribirlo y sacar todo el dolor y la
rabia como lo que está envilanas de TIC
no una manera de nombrar estas historias
desgarradoras que tenemos para luego
también empezar con nuestro proceso de
sanación no y decir bueno viví esto pero
tengo la fuerza de las abuelas para
salir de este espacio y poder nombrarlo
y muchas gracias No a ti pues muchas
gracias por la invitación mi muy
lagemundún mucha boquita cunimé janosos
[Música]